Did you see the video of the poachers
that went to kill the rhino and the lion?
The lion killer video of
it. I saw a picture. I still
still picture. Oh, okay. Yeah.
I didn't know if they got a
video, but yeah, that's fucked up.
That's fucking a few duets
got jacked, right. Sweet.
Even that's the lions and we even
look at this. Turn up the volume.
Jamie.
Look,
I don't want to [inaudible] Shit.
Okay.
I don't want to use my bear spray.
He said that's a good boy.
That's a good boy too.
He's coming around.
That's good. Okay. Come forward.
Yes. My things mother
motherfuckers, it's following them.
It's circling them around.
Yeah. He's cute. I mean that
thing is circling him, man.
It's going towards him. That's
a good boy. Yeah. The thing is,
the thing is coming way too close to
him, man. It's like going in a circle.
Okay.
Crappies huge. Hell No.
Yeah, they got lucky there.
I would have been gone.
The scary thing about that is that bear
could have just decided randomly through
some firing of his bare synapses to take
a left instead of right. Yes, go at him.
He just,
he could have easily decided that all
those things crazy scare the shit out of
me. You know why man? We don't
believe in things we don't see.
We don't believe in them.
What do you mean you don't believe in
things you don't see? You know it's real,
but you don't believe danger. No,
you don't believe in it. It's not.
It's not a real thing in your
world. Right? Right. When you,
if you were outside and you saw that, if
you will, with those people in Australia,
you, you Biller, oh Jesus Christ.
This is what I know. If I was there,
I would know that that's the
reality. That's really like
my world. Does it evolve?
Does it involve being somewhere
near that close to a bear?
So to see it in my world would be
what? The F W I wouldn't be real. No.
Like holy shit, this can't be happening.
But if you were with those people,
if you went on that trip with the odd
beat, that would be fucking fell out.
One of the craziest things
you get out with you,
your whole existence gets down to the
chance that this thing makes a decision to
go one way or another. Yeah. Otherwise
it's just going to run you down.
Just like less like life. If you go in
a certain scenario scenarios you like,
wait, this shit can get real
real fast. Real fast know. Yeah.
That's one of them man. That his life, any
inner city life is just like holy shit.
It's about of a pop off
in here. Yeah. Right.
How many people died in Chicago last
week? Some insane number. There was a,
the reporting on uh,
the lack of attention that the murders
in Chicago are getting and like the
national news and how crazy it is. Right.
How good. The Chicago several times.
The one thing that sticks
out to me every time I go,
there's how segregated it this.
Yeah.
I've never gone made you aware of
a major city like New York is like,
we're all right.
Piled up together for killed 24
wounded and weekend shootings.
God, 28 people got shot. Dude,
that is crazy.
28 over the weekend in the afternoon
and say fuck standing on a sidewalk
wouldn't fire Jesus Christ. There is a,
there is a war going on in Chicago that's
way more deadly than most of the wars
were engaging in overseas.
You don't hear about that many soldiers
dying every day. Now that's another,
that's another scenario how we said like
that's real. Yeah, that's real. Right?
But here's real asked.
You are there outside in Chicago.
That is a real fear that you should
have and this is what's crazy number of
people in Chicago.
That's your passes.
1400 1400 people shot.
Now how many people do we
know how many got shot?
Like doing tours of Afghanistan?
That's a good question.
What does this, this is the over the
year this does this year. Sure. Yeah.
Okay, so let's Google. How many
soldiers were shot overseas this year?
You know the, that's a weird
thing man. We got a war going on.
If that was Mexicans invading North
Dakota and shooting people now,
many people were dying every day
we would be taking action. Who,
because it's happening to people is
1400 and a hundred of them were white
people. It would be an issue. Oh yeah.
It was 1300 black people in 100 white
people. It'd be, yeah, we shut it down.
You really, right. This is, I mean,
it's something that people don't talk
about this 300. I mean, he's like, uh,
be crazy.
That's a weird statistic.
It's a terrible situation.
Like culturally to have
something like this is hilarious.
And with 1400 people being shot,
that means,
and people don't want to realize this is,
you know,
post traumatic stress disorder is a real
thing in the ghetto as well as in the
hills of Afghanistan. It's real, of
course. So when you see something that,
when people were like, why these guys
have guns on them? It's like, dude,
1400 people got shot. I'm just trying
to get to school and back. Yeah.
I'm trying to get to work and
back. Of course it's, you know,
we're not protecting those people.
It's exactly,
if they were stuck somewhere overseas
in some, in the middle of some war,
you know, and they were American citizens
and be like, please help get us out of,
you've got to get these good.
If there was a place that
had like statistically the
numbers of the south side
of Chicago where all this,
the murder's going down,
there was a place statistically in
another part of the world, right.
We would be set those numbers
anywhere else. And it's a,
it's a crisis. If we had,
so let's say Hawaii, let's say if we
had just moved into Hawaii, right?
Like just just took over Hawaii and then
we're in an area where people started
getting shot at and killed by local
site that we would want to read,
want to extract those people from Hawaii.
We'd scoop them up from an island.
We would think they'd be shooting at the
helicopter says we restaurant. Right,
right. Well you just look at the
real numbers. Just the raw numbers.
That's a crazy number of people
getting shot this year. This is July,
so I just started how
many soldiers got shot?
I can't find trying to find wounded.
I can only find a deaths. Okay.
What's it deaths?
It's only like 1500 total since like
2001 since 2001 man or 26 January.
It seems weird saying only
I know what you're saying.
You just saying in comparison to the
other number since January. Yeah.
That's insane. That's
crazy. That is insane.
And that's happening right
here in the good old us of a,
in one of the biggest cities in the
world. Chicago's giant, awesome city.
And it's happening in other cities
also that people don't know about,
but Chicago is the most glaring. Yeah,
because I don't travel around there,
so I don't know a what
happened or why it happened,
why they have this segregation
there and what it was. All right.
Go to Chicago, man. It's like black
people all the way over there.
Then it's downtown where it's
nice and everybody's, you know,
Detroit has that too, right? It's
right as well. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
man. Then you go down south. It's
like that. You go to Louisiana.
It was crazy. You were the king
or the president. Tony Rock.
I was the president.
How do you fix this? Uh,
you have to fix this. It's
a process, man. First,
I always say number one is education,
right? Education is number one.
If you're just,
if you're getting a better education
than you just avoid the pitfalls and
naturally because you just know that
these certain things are wrong. And,
and by getting a badge at
better education, I mean you
have opportunities to do,
you know, you have a music appreciation,
you have the arts, you have sports,
you have things to occupy you during
school hours and after school hours.
There's no type of any
type of extra curricular,
extra curricular activities for these
kids. In Chicago. There's gang life,
which you are born into,
which you are expected to go
into once you are a certain age.
You all right your man. Now here's
the gun. We don't like those guys.
Those guys don't like us.
You don't even question it.
It's like my father has been this way.
My grandfather has been this way.
My uncles a display, my big brothers
to this way, you don't even,
you're born right into it. You don't
want it in a war zone, all right?
And you don't question it.
And it's a war zone where you
sleep and your family lives, right.
Not just a war zone with soldiers,
but a war zone with families.
And another thing better education you,
you're more worldly.
If you see the world, you
realize how small that, how
small your neighborhood is.
And there's a bigger world out there
and you could want to go places and see
things and then you realize
like what are we doing here?
But these are people that I guarantee
probably never left Chicago,
probably never went on vacation to the
south to visit grandparents and realize,
damn,
the south is nice and quiet and the
people are friendly and they've never been
to the zoo and saw animal and went home
and googled the mating rituals of this.
Open your mind, open your
mind, you see the world,
the stuff that you're involved in
becomes just so small. This guy,
I don't let Scott cause he has one red
and I have on blue, I don't get it.
So the education,
that tiny little
area, you know, that he operates
in with his living his life,
it does matter.
It's a reality. Right? The reality is
what's around you. Yeah. That's what,
until you get a scope of a bigger world.
Like I grew up in the hood,
I grew up in bed Stuy,
Brooklyn,
but one of the wildest neighborhoods
when I was going up there,
but my vision was passed it. My vision
was, yeah, this is going on outside,
but I'm going to be there one day.
What do you attribute the,
having the ability to do that to uh,
having a mom and a dad?
I pops, my father worked two full
time jobs my whole childhood.
My father literally
worked 80 hours a week,
80 so just to see him go everyday
and like, damn this dude,
this dude works hard man.
Wow.
Didn't have a lot to show for it and made
sure his kids had, mom was a teacher.
Education was, she'd been an
emphasis on it. Wow. You know,
it was, it was just like my friends, my,
my, one of my best friends down the block.
No Dad, my friend across the street, no
dad, my friend, two doors down, no dad.
Then crack came and that was everything
fucked up. Everything started.
Just the neighborhood started just to, you
know. Yeah. That was like a revelation.
Crack was people that
are alive today or young kids today,
they don't remember the eighties yeah,
there was a like a
plague. Yup. A plane hit.
Everybody knew somebody that got hit
and so many people's lives were gone,
done, done over. People who were
doing fine and then all of a sudden,
yeah, Yup, I remember it.
I remember it well. Yeah.
It was a weird kind of way to start
losing friends. That's what I,
that's what happened. I started losing
friends. I, I saw it like people don't,
it was crazy man. Like
Shit. When the shit we saw,
I saw a friend get shot in the head,
like talk to him on the corner.
Engaged. What's up man? Yeah, we gonna
play ball lady. You wouldn't play ball.
All right, cool. I'll hit you
later. Turned to walk down
the block. Look that maybe,
you know, a thousand feet away and
looked back to like just, you know,
looking around the neighborhood and saw
a guy just bang, got kinda like he was,
he looked like, if you ever see
an old like big daddy Kane album,
he had the flat top and a bunch of jewelry
on, on the corner, on the pay phone.
This is beeper days, you
know, and you got to turn.
And the guy ran up on him while he was
returning a beep and just tried to rob
him. And then he went for his gun and
the guy just boom right in his head,
right on the corner of my
block, brightest, right
on the corner of my block.
And I went home and my parents are
there and I was like, this is crazy man.
And that's where I grew up. But my
vision was not confined to where I was.
It was, I'm going to be, you know,
fortunately I get out of here,
I'm going to do this and once
I leave here, I'm going to,
you're very fortunate to have
those kinds of examples. You know,
if your dad who worked out that and your
mom, very fortunate. That's awesome.
Yeah,
man,
it's hard for some people if they didn't
get the break that you got in that
regard.
That's why I don't, I,
it's not missed on me.
Like I realized like if I didn't get
that, I didn't catch that last Chapa. Hmm.
Good for you, man. That's uh, but that's,
that's where character comes from to mean
having someone like that as an example.
Like how someone who can work two
full time jobs. Yeah. And that is,
that's a force of will most people
struggle with one man. One is hard,
eight hours a day and he makes it time.
My Dad's rule was everybody had to have
a job at 1413 was your last summer.
Enjoy yourself at the ball, do whatever
you wanna do. 14 you getting a job.
Wow. Yep. No, he didn't play at all.
14 job since those,
he's,
the thing is, man, that's a bitter pill
to swallow when you're young, but damn,
that dude's who go through that always
seem like they have an extra gear.
You know?
I know a lot of dudes who went through
like bootcamp type dads and they did not
like it,
but they can do some shit.
Like I'll just a little bit more shit
that other people could do. You know?
They might not look like the fact that
dad was always telling them what to do,
but these motherfuckers can hike 20
miles. Yeah. And not complaining.
My Dad wasn't bootcamp, but it
was like, you're going to work.
That's not even a question.
You're going to work.
And then I have so many siblings
that what his rule was, you know,
we all had to take care of each other.
So my oldest brother, of course,
he turns 14 first he's working,
he gets paid.
You have to give everybody $5 you get,
you got paid today.
Give all your siblings five dot.
Wow. Next brother gets a job.
Now it's two brothers working. Give
everybody $5 wow. It was like a socialism.
Yeah. My Dad just made sure it all worked.
That's cool. That's very generous too.
That's like everybody that's forcing
everybody to be in it together. Right.
That's smart. And taking Mandarin. And
then it was, the rule was it was, uh,
if your brother's in a fight,
you're in a fight.
So then it became don't
fuck with the rock brothers.
Cause there's so many of them,
you have to fight all of them.
So that kind of kept us safe during this
whole, you know, wow, that's awesome.
And what a, it's a bad
situation to be in, but, uh,
a great place to develop
character, right. Opportunities.
The right character there. Yeah. You
know who you are, you know what you're,
you know that you, you know, you
develop a, a sense of, uh, you know,
go and get it work hard. No
excuses, nobody's doing it for you.
Nobody's coming to save you. You're
responsible for you. Yeah, man,
we all need to have a little
bit more of that in our life.
And then also a little bit more
community to, you know, and I that right.
And we grew up in a time where it was
next door neighbor could spank you,
lady across the street could grab you and
make you sit down on the stupid ticket.
Mother came home,
right?
The guy in the Bodega at the corner would
tell you to sit inside and your mother
came home. Yeah, people would, uh,
they would police the neighborhood
policing we live in now. We live in,
don't talk to my kid, don't touch
my kid. Have Right. Get off my son.
Don't touch my child. You know,
there's a lot of that. Well,
it's because somebody's man,
that's the weird balance.
I talked about this recently,
but my cousin, I saw my cousin
gets smacked by some lady once
when we were, we were both like,
my cousin's a year younger than me,
so I'm might have been six and she
might've been five somewhere around there.
It wasn't any older than that.
Right.
And this lady cuffed her and
right in the face, man, she fell.
This lady fell on the ice and my cousin
just happened to be there and she was
looking at her on the ground
and she did not laugh at her,
but the lady said she laughed at and she,
the lady got up and she was just
angry that she fell and hurt herself.
She got up and smack my
cousin right in the face.
My cousin fell down and I remember
seeing it and realizing I couldn't do
anything about it to save her, to help
her. You know, I was a little kid too,
and being terrified that this grown up
person just smack this little kid in the
head for something that wasn't even real.
Right. Like you don't want that either.
Right. It's like, don't touch my
kid. It's probably better. Well,
that's in the long run.
Crazy. People smile. Helping
raise a child. That's right.
I mean, as adults, that's just a crazy,
she was a crazy lady that
lives in our building.